“No one man should have all that power.”
Literally, no one person in the world should
have too much power.
Power is quantified in our societies in different
ways; political power, systemic power,
financial power, turtle power.
All of it is tied to a hierarchical escalator
in which we rise up through decisions and actions.
But once we have power, how does it affect
our brain and behavior?
After the theme song.
(off screen)
There's still, uh, still no theme song.
OK!
Let’s define power because it’s more of
a sociological concept, but anything sociological
will have some degree of psychological effect.
The definition I’ll use is “possession
of control, authority, or influence over others.”
Having power over others, or controlling resources
that they want, need or fear – has profound
effects on the mind and brain, as does being
in a less powerful position.
There are countless super light, not traumatizing
studies looking at human behavior in positions
of power like the super chill, completely
ethical 1971 Stanford Prison Experiment where
a professor by the name of Dr. Zimbardo assigned
either guard or prisoner to subjects and basically
let human nature have creative control, and
the guards abused all of the power.
Like all of it. They left no power un-abused.
Or the wildly ethical, completely not
wack Milgram experiment, where Dr. Millgram
studied how far people would go in obeying
an instruction
if it involved harming another person. And...
"But he might be dead in there!"
...people took it to a pretty horrifying
extreme, claiming that they were “following orders."
So, you know, just some light Nazi-ing.
Clearly power corrupts, but what effect does
it actually have?
Well, it increases hypocrisy, egocentrism,
and lack of empathy which doesn’t sound
like anyone, right?
Right.
If it corrupts us, what is it actually doing
to our brains?
Well, the answer may lie in dopamine.
Dopamine is that reward neurotransmitter among
a whole score of other functions.
It’s behind some of our feel good feelings and
power makes us feel...good.
Power increases testosterone levels,
but that in turn activates dopamine activity.
An EEG study from 2012 saw increased dopaminergic
activity in the left prefrontal cortex in
individuals primed to think about a situation
where they had power over another person,
so if power is linked to reward, that might
explain why it's so hard to give up.
Releases of dopamine in your brain is reward-
oriented, and when you get dopamine, you want
more and more. It’s a large focus of addiction
research.
People want that high whether it's a drug,
a feeling, or both like a Wolf of Wall Street
type high, all the money and power,
and then all the cocaina.
This is where the neurochemistry of power
comes into play.
More power often comes with more resources,
which could be more money, more subordinates,
etc etc.
That same dopamine can enhance cognitive function,
but also may make people more impulsive,
less risk-averse, and less empathetic.
Sound familiar?
It should.
Philosopher and neuroscientist
Nayef Al-Rodhan suggests that in a power paradigm,
high levels of dopamine are associated with
a sense of personal destiny, risk-taking,
preoccupation with the cosmic or religious,
and emotional detachment that can lead to
becoming more callous and singularly focused
on achieving goals.
There’s nothing wrong with ambition; we
should all want to do stuff, stuff is always
good, but there’s truth to the phrase that “power
corrupts,” and it doesn’t take a Dr. Zimbardo
to expose that.
Having a degree of power causes people to
detach from humanity in a way, lowering the
ability to comprehend how other people see,
think, and feel, also known as another idiom,
“walking in another person’s shoes.”
Further research out of Canada put people
with and without power in a transcranial magnetic
resonance machine and found that power impaired
a specific neural process that we’ll call
'mirroring,' which people think is key in
having and expressing empathy.
Empathy is a key part of being a
human being, yes, but it's also
important in campaigning for office; knowing what
your constituents see, think, and feel and
running on those issues and platforms.
But it seems that as power increases, this
sort of empathic response deteriorates and
when subjects with power are asked to act
empathically, they are often really, really bad at it.
Why? Well, some theorize that an increase in power
lessens the need for an understanding of people
with less power, because it gives them access
to resources that they didn't previously have,
like that friend acting differently
when they found that higher class of friends
with more social status or started acting
different when they finally got some bread.
Or lettuce.
Or cheese.
Why is everything about money also about sandwiches?
The science behind it suggests that powerful people may be hooked on power,
losing the ability to have genuine empathy, and becoming myopically focused.
And that's not just politicians.
Need a key to staying grounded?
Research says have a tether, reminding
you not to believe your own hype.
Mine’s my mom and my friends, Karen and Rhonda.
This episode is brought to you by
your hype: don't believe it.
Rainbow.
Ok, so you're in a powerful position,
and you're making people under you feel
like they're not as powerful. Well,
watch this video about rehumanization
so you don't see them as objects.
Come on, man. You can do better.
Just watch the video.
Thanks for watching and make sure to subscribe, dude.
I'm asking nicely.
You won't like me when I'm angry.
I just get softer.